[Music]
the devastation was sweeping more than
69,000 death homes and jobs lost an
instant
amidst the human tragedy it's sometimes
hard to remember that the massive
earthquake in China also affected wildly
[Music]
conservationists were particularly
concerned about the nation's hypersonic
animal the giant panda the quakes
epicenter was just 20 miles from the
nation's remote Wolong Panda reserve in
central China where these endangered
animals are bred and protected National
Geographic dispatched a team to assess
the damage getting to the site was
extremely difficult
[Music]
the magnitude 7.9 earthquake ravaged the
landscape
[Applause]
sometimes impassable and landslides were
a constant threat
when they finally reach the reserved the
TV discovered that some of the centre's
buildings have been destroyed
when it slides had very part of the
pandas habitat Zhang Haman is the
director of the reserve power station
[Music]
collapsed some witnesses say the pandas
to sense trouble before the earthquake
struck freezing in their tracks
[Music]
fortunately most of the animals and
their caretakers were outside when the
quake struck and not trapped inside the
collapsed buildings but the Templar was
strong enough to toss boulders the size
of cars crumbling buildings and burying
valleys
some workers gathered up the babies in
their arms and sprinted up a ladder
that's life
staff members died one panda perish
another that was missing
it's own to the Haven in the days after
the disaster but the crisis wasn't over
yet
the pandas food source was now in
jeopardy an adult panda browses through
a whopping 44 pounds of fresh bamboo
each day so much that the meals have to
be trucked in from outside farms
[Music]
with the regular supply roads cut off
the Chinese government arranged an
emergency bamboo shipment to the center
[Music]
many of the keepers are still here
working in some cases without
electricity and despite the quakes
trauma to their own lives China is
committed to saving its best known
species only about 1,600
in the wild and only about a hundred and
eighty have been bred in captivity the
wool reserve is working to successfully
release captive-bred pandas into the
wild those plans may be on hold as
conservationists continue to reassess
damage from the quake many of the pandas
in the woollen reserve have already been
moved to a safer and perhaps more
suitable habitat conservationists say
the pandas should have a breeding center
in the mountains where there's an
abundant supply of bamboo and water a
place where they can live in a more
natural habitat
after this disaster of horrific
proportions conservationists hope for
better things to come safety sponsored
by National Geographic mission programs
taking science and exploration into the
new millennium